these brothers left the Democratic
Republic of Congo 3 years ago they
traveled to Zambia then into Zimbabwe
when they crossed the border into South
Africa their mother was killed in a bus
accident they are still traumatized but
being undocumented means they can't
easily get help I started the process of
taking this one at the hospital I'm sure
maybe the social worker never wanted to
tell me openly but I'm sure because of
documentation that they never admitted
you cuz the way you see him you'll think
he's F but not fine he's not fine at
all South Africa is trying to clear a
backlog of applications from Asylum
Seekers and refugees some didn't qualify
for Asylum and they are appealing
against that decision the government is
working with the UN Refugee Agency on
how to deal with the backlog in
processing Refugee and Asylum
applications some of the applicants come
from countries such as the Democratic
Republic of Congo Ethiopia and Somalia
human rights lawyers say thousands of
people are waiting for documents to
legally live and work here some are
economic migrants others have fled
conflict in their countries it's very
hard for people to access documentation
and you know where like uh documentation
is the Cornerstone to everything so if
you do not have documents you can't
access your uh Health Care children have
problems with accessing their schooling
and opening bank accounts working and
things like that home Affairs officials
say the department is scaling up
resources staff and Technical equipment
to try and deal with the backlogs until
that has effect David and his brothers
can only wait and hope for the best har
matasa aljazera
ptor